In March 2021, at the height of the coronavirus
pandemic, four of Europe's most powerful women
sent a letter to Brussels.
It included a dire warning.
The pandemic had shown how much the EU
depends on foreign technology, they wrote
— and this needs to change.
Their language was diplomatic — but the underlying
message was clear: It’s time to rein in Big Tech.
“Tech giants will have to change
the way they do business…”
"…an unprecedented amount of pressure…”
“A Day of Reckoning…”
"Mr. Zuckerberg, I just
want a Yes or No answer. Mr. Pichai, Yes or No?"
Governments around the globe have set their
eyes on the world’s largest tech companies.
But how did Big Tech come under so much fire?
And how did it get so “Big” in the first place?
We might not always notice it — but technology is
all around us. We use it to communicate, to get
information, to organize our lives. And almost all
that technology is made by private companies.
This has given rise to an industry known as Big
Tech. And within this industry, four companies
have become especially powerful:  Alphabet —
which owns Google — Amazon, Facebook and Apple.
In fact, they’re so big now they’re known as
the “Big Four,” or by their acronym “GAFA.”
Those “Big Four” actually run fairly different
businesses. But what they have in common is
that they provide digital services — and they have
become so ingrained in our lives that it’s almost
impossible to avoid them.
Take me, for example:
My phone is made by Apple. And when I
use it to surf the internet, that traffic
likely runs through servers owned by Amazon.
Or let’s talk about you: There’s a good chance
you’re watching this video on YouTube,
which is owned by Google. And you might
have come across it on Facebook.
The point is: Big Tech is everywhere.
And this has made the companies very, very rich.
While the coronavirus forced many businesses
to down shutters and plunged the
world economy into a recession,
Big Tech is reporting enormous profits.
The stock prizes of all Big Four have skyrocketed:
Some, like Apple’s, doubled in value
since the beginning of the pandemic
But many would argue that this
success comes with responsibility —
and increasingly, people are asking if …
"…those company are living up
to that responsibility?"
“No, and I don't think we
should expect of Big Tech to be benevolent.”
“They have been trying but it’s really hard.“
“The answer to that depends on
where you are talking from.”
Let’s untangle this. The core criticism
of Big Tech comes down to four points:
It’s about how the companies:
—protect the privacy of their users
—can be held liable for what’s
happening on their platforms
—pay their taxes and
—how they treat their competitors
And when it comes to the first point — privacy
— Big Tech has been under fire for years.
But it wasn’t always that way: The birth of
Big Tech dates back to the Silicon Valley
of the late 1990s and early 2000s, when
most of the companies were founded.
Their missions were ambitious: The startups
were out to disrupt the status quo,
connect people and give them
unprecedented access to information.
And when a decade later, protests
spread across the Arab world,
many saw that as proof for how the technology
could, indeed, be a force for democracy.
And it was. But what people
didn’t pay much attention to
was how Big Tech actually makes money:
Most of the companies got big by providing
free services — while, in exchange, collecting
data about their users and selling ads.
And another couple of years later, the Cambridge
Analytica scandal helped many understand that this
very data could also be used to manipulate them.
When reports emerged that a consultancy had mined
information about millions of Facebook users
to influence how they voted in the UK’s Brexit
referendum and the 2016 US election, that
changed how people looked at Big Tech.
“Especially in the United
States, I think, for a long time,
it was seen as a source of strength.
But the idea that there could be groups
inside the United States that were using those
alleged champions of the United States to turn
their pride into a vulnerability, has
really hit home for a lot of Americans.”
Since then, stricter data protection laws
have been passed around the world.
The full truth is that they
haven’t always been enforced.
But increasingly, regulators and courts
are doing just that — and that’s one reason
why Big Tech is feeling the heat.
The second one is that more attention is paid to
liability — the question of who’s
responsible for what’s being said
or done on the platforms run by Big Tech.
“Supporters of US President Trump have
stormed the Capitol building to support his
latest effort to overturn his election defeat”
It’s a question experts have been debating for
years. But it only moved to the front pages
when in January 2021, following online calls
for violence, a mob stormed the US Capitol.
“What happened on January 6 has definitely
mainstreamed this conversation,”
“But we should note that even before
the capitol storming, we were already
talking about liability of social media platforms,
when we talked about Myanmar, for instance.”
Years earlier, nationalists in Myanmar had
already used Facebook to foment violence against
the country’s Rohingya minority.
“Facebook didn’t even notice that
because they didn’t have anyone speaking
the local languages and they didn’t have
anyone monitoring the situation in Myanmar.”
“They have grown even faster than they could think
about what kind of responsibility comes with that
growth — and that has been one of the problems.”
Facebook has acknowledged mistakes in
Myanmar, hired more local language
experts and pledged to do better.
But increasingly, governments say that
such pledges alone aren’t enough. Some,
including Germany, have therefore passed
laws that force the platforms to quickly take
down incendiary posts or face big fines.
And speaking of money — there’s a third reason
why Big Tech is under fire: Taxes.
For years, critics have said that the
companies aren’t paying their fair share of
taxes — both when it comes to how much they’re
paying and where they’re paying them.
“The problem here is that governments,
both in the United States and Europe, have
given them a lot of space to go to the lowest
point of taxes — to use the loopholes to deploy
their armies of lawyers and accountants all
over the world to place profits in other
parts of the world where they were actually
made and to really move the accounting around.”
NGOs estimate that in 2020 alone,
a group of 20 countries in the Global South missed
out on almost 700 million Euro from Facebook
and over 765 million Euro from
Google’s parent company Alphabet.
“Big Technology companies like
Facebook, Google and Amazon
will soon be paying more taxes in France…”
Some countries have introduced national taxes
to make the companies pay at least some
taxes where people use their services.
But many believe that a global tax is needed.
International talks were stalled
by the Trump administration.
The Biden administration has signalled willingness
to come back to the table. Some hope for a deal
by this summer. But that’s far from certain.
And taxes aside, some people also say the
companies have simply become too big.
Which brings us to the final issue: competition.
And, once again, it helps to go back in time.
This man is John D. Rockefeller. Over a century
ago, he was essentially what Jeff Bezos or
Mark Zuckerberg are today.
Rockefeller had built up an
empire that controlled over 90
percent of oil in the U.S.
This made him the richest man of his time.
But people said his success
was built on unfair practices.
And in 1911, the US Supreme Court ruled to
split up his corporation into 34 companies.
Fast forward by 110 years and you will hear
people say similar things about Big Tech.
In late 2020, US Democrats said in a
report that every one of the “Big Four”
runs a monopoly like “the kinds of monopolies
we last saw in the era of oil barons.”
Companies, they said, effectively have to
sell their products on Amazon’s marketplace
because they have no “viable alternative.”
Apple, they added, gets to decide what software
people use on their phones — and charges
“supra-competitive prices” to developers.
Facebook bought up companies
like Instagram or WhatsApp
whenever they were about to become serious
competitors, according to the lawmakers.
And Google has favored its own services
in its search engine and advertising
business, the report said.
The companies reject those claims:
Amazon has dismissed them as “interventions
in the free market.” Apple says it does not
overcharge developers. Facebook argues that all
its acquisitions were approved by regulators.
And Google says that, unlike what the report
claims, it still does have strong competitors.
But this hasn’t stopped U.S. and other
governments from launching antitrust cases
against the companies.
And some are even asking:
What if we go back to what was done
110 years ago, and break up Big Tech?
Make no mistake: That would be incredibly
difficult and messy, and it’s completely
unclear if any kind of break-up will
happen — but the debate is gathering speed.
“I don’t know to what extent
it would solve all the problems
we have with big tech.”
“In some ways, breaking
up a company is a remedy of last resort.”
“It’s a threat to our democracy if any single
company has so much power. And we already see
how much lobbying power they have and how much
money they’re spending trying to influence
not just politics, but NGOs, research.”
Around the world, Big Tech is spending more
than ever on lobbying: In Brussels, for example,
the Big Four spent at least 15 million Euro in
2020, according to the EU’s lobbying register.
They have their reasons: The bloc is working on
landmark legislation to both curb the market power
of Big Tech and hold companies accountable
for what’s happening on their platforms.
And it was against that backdrop
that the leaders of Germany, Finland,
Denmark and Estonia sent their letter in March.
“As Europeans, we aspire to continue asserting
our democratic values and rules in
the digital era,” they wrote.
And they concluded by calling on Brussels to
“put the weight of the European Commission
behind this joint endeavour.”
It was their way of saying:
Time to get tough on Big Tech.